i believe the democrats are
intentionally destroying america here's
joe biden on
inflation and what causes it and what
does it cause it
i'm sick of this stuff
[Applause]
we have to talk about it because the
american people think the reason for
inflation is government spending more
money
simply not true
by simply not true he means true he
means totally absolutely true
the government has a certain amount of
money where does the government get that
money it gets it from taxes so then
there's a certain amount of money now we
already have a huge amount of debt so
when we get money we don't have a
surplus of money we just have
potentially a little less debt but of
course with the interest rates and
everything else we're always just
driving ourselves into more debt that's
why the national debt grows literally
every day and it grows by i don't know
probably grows by hundreds of millions
of dollars every half hour or something
we figure out how fast it grows like how
much more debt are we in from when i
start this show every day to when i end
this show let's figure out give me
something on roughly how quickly this
thing is growing there's got to be some
calculator online somewhere with a very
very long number that's going to
ultimately crash the internet
the idea that when the government just
makes up money just prints more money
literally it's just imaginary based on
nothing throws it into the economy the
idea that that has nothing to do with
inflation or increasing the debt or
screwing over our economy is completely
insane it's completely insane it has
nothing to do with reality has nothing
to do with basic economics and is an
absolute lie and that's why when he i'm
sick of it
that's why he's pretending to have human
emotion because that's what they're
really good at right he whispers
sometimes to say certain things and i'm
sick of that thing he's doing it all
based on fake emotion because the
reality of the policies is what is
destroying things if he is literally
sitting in a room
at the big
you know
he's in the oval office they got the two
yellow couches and the little coffee
table and he's at his desk and they got
all the people in there and if he's
sitting in a room with 15 people and
they're all like yes yes put more money
into the economy print more money it
won't cause any inflation it won't do
anything bad to the economy then all of
those people should be fired or should
be examined mentally for not
understanding basic i think seventh
grade economics something like that
it never ends with these clowns here's
elizabeth warren she is a fake native
american who is a senator up in
massachusetts saying that inflation has
nothing to do with the policies that
they're pushing nothing to do with these
people it's a whole bunch of other
people their problems simple question to
you is what causes it and if i were to
read a lot of what you've said and
written
i would leap to the conclusion that you
think the primary cause of it is
corporate greed whether it's the oil
companies whether it's software
companies whether it's food processing
companies what causes inflation so i
think the primary cause of this bout of
price increases starts with coving
but what has also happened
is that now that we live in america
where there's a lot more concentration
in certain industries look at the oil
industry look at
meat industry look at groceries
generally
that what's happened is these companies
have said
you know we'll pass along costs but
while we're at it and everyone's talking
about rising costs let's just add an
extra big dollop
of cost increases to expand our profits
liz okay first off none of this was
happening under the orange man okay so
you people took power your stupid
socialist ideas took over and that's
when the [ __ ] started to hit the fan so
was it suddenly that when they got rid
of orange man and mr mental [ __ ] took
over suddenly the meat packing people
were like yes let's really push it now
and increase the cost of hamburgers
because we got rid of trump it's
complete nonsense the people that are
pushing all of the [ __ ] on you and
who are lying about everything and
causing inflation causing you to spend
more on basic goods causing gas prices
to go up causing hamburger meat to cost
more and everything else are blaming the
people who produce those things do you
understand that they're blaming the very
people who produce those things in a
capitalist society where there is
competition to drive those costs down
but then when the government comes in
pumps a whole bunch of money and money
becomes worthless inflation starts going
up and then the companies are like boy
we're looking at our margins right now
and we have to start charging more
because we're not making as much money
she is a
liar a liar and a buffoon
yeah the meat people i love it the me
it's the meat people and it's the tech
people and the gas station people you
know there's nothing worse than a greedy
gas station owner
liar
liar
fake native american i don't like you